el malestar se originó cuando el reino
unido decidió abandonar europa los
críticos británicos señalaron que
francia fue uno de los negociadores más
duros del break sheet culpando a parís
de un difícil divorcio mientras que el
elíseo acusa a downing street- de
incumplir lo pactado durante las
negociaciones de salida el conflicto
pesquero es sólo el último de los
ejemplos según el gobierno francés la
gestión migratoria es uno de los puntos
de discordia según reino unido 18.000
personas cruzaron el canal de la mancha
clandestinamente desde el inicio del año
la pandemia de kobe 19 también
desencadenó discusiones el reino unido-
miró por sus propios intereses con
oxford astrazéneca y dejó que europa se
arreglará por su cuenta luego el
presidente macrón expresó sus dudas
sobre el fármaco británico la decisión y
haití son comités y es la decisión que
hemos tomado de acuerdo con las
políticas europeas es suspender
provisionalmente la vacuna de
astrazéneca
las declaraciones de macrón llegaron
poco después de que francia bloqueara la
entrada a su territorio de camiones
provenientes del reino unido justo antes
de navidad evocando razones sanitarias
street lo considero como una estrategia
para lograr mejores condiciones en el
acuerdo del break sito hace poco francia
se mostró traicionada por la
participación del reino unido en la
alianza o cus y el consiguiente pacto de
submarinos con australia que hizo perder
a parís miles de millones de euros
después de que camberra se decantará por
las naves nucleares estadounidenses y
británicas en detrimento de las
francesas
boris johnson ironizó sobre la furia del
elíseo
tranquilícense denme un respiro
y
una humillación para el gobierno de
macrón y una prueba de que el reino
unido cuenta con socios comerciales más
allá de europa